[Music]
pretty badass you know suited up for
battle but looking like VPS drivers
super cool go Brown between you and
Christian I mean who's the good cop and
who's the bad cop when it comes to the
kids like who lays down the law at your
household I don't know that anyone's
laying down the law but I'm probably
more the disciplinary oh yeah yeah well
I won again I don't know about crack in
the web but this job is my one shot at
save me my marriage what are you wearing
my uniform where the kids on set were
their staple with you guys while you're
making yeah weld on the days I wasn't
working I brought them and we just all
hung out with that he's laying down the
law in your household you know nobody
because we have a dialogue with them
where it's just there are things that
are acceptable things that are not so we
don't there's no bad cop like enforcing
anything it's just like well if you did
that you lose this and that's
everything's very calm in our household
I'm we need more law enforcement like
you guys I think Mel you know it seems
to work works for three-year-olds
[Music]
you